parmi les grands perdants les avocats
actuellement un avocat perso en moyenne
de 1130 euros de retraite payées par les
nombreux actifs de la profession à
savoir 4 pour un seul retraité leur
système de cotisation et même
bénéficiaire de 2 milliards d'euros
or le nouveau régime pour absorber cette
réserve est engendré une augmentation
des cotisations en sachant
qu'aujourd'hui on cotise à hauteur de 14
% de notre chiffre d'affaires pour la
caisse de retraite
il y avait un certain nombre d'avocats
qui fonctionne à l'aide juridictionnelle
donc c'est un petit peu difficile
aujourd'hui ça va doubler à 28%
donc ça va se répercuter nécessairement
sur les charges des charges de ses
avocats est donc un danger pour ces
petits un vocable le monde de
l'enseignement qui est aussi sa colère
avec la réforme la retraite sera
déterminé en fonction de l'ensemble de
leur carrière et non sur les six
derniers mois
les professeurs seront donc perdant
puisque les salaires des six derniers
mois sont nécessairement plus élevé le
président l'a dit lui-même je crois
puisqu'il a annoncé que c'est ce qu'à
1200 euros donc ça fait 1000 euros de
moins donc on est presque sûr du
j'annonçais 30% on est plus près de 40%
en fait je ne vois pas quel métier
pourrait accepter un tel écart c'est
proprement inadmissible inadmissible
c'est ce que pense aussi
ce policier d'autant plus que les
grandes lignes de la réforme restent
floues pour la profession aujourd'hui un
certain nombre de points qui sont pas
vraiment claires notamment sur la
bonification le statut spécial l'équité
qu'il peut y avoir entre
l'inéquité plus tant de fois la police
gendarmerie parce qu'aujourd'hui c'est
quelque chose qui n'est pas du tout
clair non plus donc on entend plein de
choses mais on n'a pas de réponses
précises sur l'impact que cela peut
avoir
et sur ce qui va être proposé pour les
policiers une réunion des syndicats de
police se tiendra à paris ce vendredi au
ministère de l'intérieur
elle portera sur la réforme des
retraites